let's talk about Riley Keough because we
know that she is dealing with a lot in
her personal life but in her
professional life Riley's thriving
thanks to her leading role in Daisy
Jones and the six
you got the Rockstar DNA and it came
flying out of you sis well that was also
extensive rehearsal
for Riley this Series has quote brought
a lot of Joy we're told raising her baby
girl and mourning the loss of mom Lisa
Marie while working has made it a very
hard year battling with Grandmother
Priscilla over the estate has made her
deeply upset but she is hopeful
everything in her family will work out
the next court date is May 16th I want
to make a record what's next for Riley
well she just presented her directorial
debut War Pony at the South by Southwest
Festival the film focuses on two young
men growing up on a reservation this
film was made with so much love and I
think that that can come across on
screen the passion project took four
years to develop Riley shot the movie in
2019 before Daisy Jones can we get a
season two revisit see with the band you
want a season two you need to tell
Amazon
always sign up basically of course the
New York Times best seller turned series
is inspired by Fleetwood Mac and
internet sleuths are obsessing over the
comparison between Stevie Nicks and her
ex Lindsey Buckingham's performance of
breakup Anthem Silver Springs to this
concert in the show
[Applause]
[Music]
E.T spoke with Stevie after Lindsay quit
the group in the 80s needless to say
it's a
it's happier
we don't fight
and so that's a pleasure
[Music]